and we were making so much more money on
this small Channel than we'd ever made
on the big 2 million subscriber channel
so what it really comes down to is
becoming the go-to person in a niche
that has growing demand and that has
good product Market fit instead of
looking at people who are doing the same
kind of content you're doing and trying
to pull a lot of inspiration from them
look at somebody who's in another Niche
that you're interested in and ask
yourself like how can I pull a little
bit of what they're doing and bring it
over here because that's where you get
like the whole steal like an artist
ethos right
is it possible to earn over a million
dollars a year from a small Channel well
today on the think media podcast I'm
talking with Thomas Frank who actually
left his over 2 million subscriber
channel to start a new channel that
generated over 1.4 million dollars in
just a year and in this episode he's
gonna be breaking down what he did some
tips from that lesson and in general
he's a genius when it comes to
productivity mindset personal
development so this should be a powerful
episode that you're definitely going to
want to stick around until the end for
but Thomas how's it going it is going
very well super pumped to be hanging out
with you and uh as we get into some
tactics heavy information uh for those
that are maybe just meeting you give a
little bit of context to your history
yeah so I'll wait to this camera but I'm
gonna talk to you for the most part I
started making YouTube content 2014
mostly for college students uh before
that I was a blogger making blog posts
and podcasts for college students
basically how to study better how to be
more productive how to get your first
job out of college that kind of thing
moved on to General productivity for
professionals as I got older and then I
started dinking around with notion in
2018 and for those of you who don't know
notion is productivity software that is
very very customizable you can kind of
do whatever you want with it which means
that it has a very high learning curve
and in 2020 I realized there's enough of
a learning curve in this and there's
enough of an audience building up around
it that I think there's an appetite for
a channel around it so 2020 I started
making notion tutorials I made a whole
separate Channel called Thomas Frank
explains as a side project partly
because I was burned out from the main
Channel and partly because I was just
having so much fun and then 2021 rolled
around I made some products and that is
basically what I spend all my time doing
now is making notion tutorials products
in the ecosystem templates automations
that kind of thing that's amazing was it
hard to let go of a channel that grew to
2 million subscribers I mean it's still
there it'd probably still bringing in
some revenue from videos that are still
being watched but you haven't uploaded
in a year was that hard decision to make
about a year and six months since I
uploaded it uh and the funny thing is I
didn't make the decision to abandon the
channel it just sort of happened so I
launched a product last year and my
intention was okay I'm going to take a a
month off of the main channel to build
the product I'm going to release it and
then I'm going to get right back to
making main Channel videos
well I built the product in a month
released it and it instantly started
making about 90 grand a month and I had
no support staff and one of the things I
really wanted to offer was a dedicated
active support for my customers so I
spent about six to eight weeks doing
full-time support in our support Forum
myself and that was yet another month or
two not publishing and then I hired a
team to do support and I spent another
month onboarding them and then I just
went through all these different little
projects and we were making so much more
money on this small Channel than we'd
ever made on the big 2 million
subscriber Channel meanwhile I'm having
more fun than ever because this is
perfectly aligned with my nerdy Tech
brain so it's just like a okay we'll get
to the main Channel next month we'll get
to the main Channel next month and we're
finally to a point where next month we
actually will get to the main Channel
I've hired people to help me with
scripts and I've hired people to help me
with editing so we're getting back to
that machine so I'm going to call it a
side quest not an abandoning of the main
thing and a switching over permanently
so your main channel will actually
become your side quest I think so yes
and then the side quest becomes the main
quest and vice versa that's amazing and
it's that speaks to just how exciting
the Creator economy can be and how much
longevity that's inspiring that you've
been in the crater economy for a long
time and so to be clear on the product
you launched like what's the website for
the product thomasjfrank.com and you can
just go to notion templates at the top
and you'll find the products and is it
so it's multiple different templates yes
and and aggregate together their digital
products that plug into notion uh yeah
they're basically notion pages I share
so notion starts as a blank canvas there
are some templates that they have which
are very basic but if you want something
a bit more advanced like say you're a
creator with a team and you want a full
pipeline from ideation of your content
to having an archive where you can
analyze performance go back in see your
scripts all that kind of stuff we turn
that into a product similarly we turned
uh my my want for an all-in-one
productivity system into a product as
well and what are the price ranges of
these uh ultimate brain right now is 1
129 and then creators companion the
highest end is 199 and then we have a
bundle which is 229 to get everything
yep so that is the highest ticket
product we sell what is the General
Revenue range monthly now right now
between like 110 and 145 per month and
how do you Market it just YouTube
organic just YouTube organic and I guess
SEO if you want to say that as well
um so yes for most notion tutorial
videos I will also try to create a
written resource and then um beyond the
videos we've also created some bigger
resources so one thing notion really
never did was made like a full-on
documentation site for their formulas
feature which is very similar to excel
formulas so kind of complicated to learn
I spent four months writing full-on
developer style documentation for that
as well so we get a lot of site traffic
and uh and then mostly YouTube traffic
as well and do how big is your team for
the notion Side of Things become that's
a good question I wouldn't say that we
have like a clear separation between the
notion side and the other side like my
editor Tony I especially has the biggest
overlap between the two because he'll
work on all the videos but the team is
10 people now do you write your own
blogs or do you have a writer for like
the blogs I write my own blogs at this
point okay so you write your own blogs
that have done the SEO oh yes you come
up with the video content uh yep on that
ocean side what are the roles of the
team so we have two full-time support
people we have an Ops director and she
is amazing her name's Marissa
um Tony is our editor and then he also
is in the studio with me so he'll also
help with camera operation he even helps
with some ideation for video topics and
when you get to 10 people it's hard to
think of everyone on the team sure um
one other person uh Eli is our full-time
developer on a software product that we
are launching hopefully next month so
don't have a ton of details on that I
can share quite yet but yeah quite a few
different things going on and what have
you learned about building a team was
that hard did that come natural uh no it
was hard yeah the main thing that I can
say I've learned and which I think will
be helpful for certain viewers is uh I
am not built to be a manager and it is
possible to build a team without having
to become a manager so I am I'm an
Explorer I'm a builder I want to learn
and build things all day long and teach
people I do not want to spend any time
giving feedback doing performance
reports any of that kind of thing
management is just not in my DNA so what
I've learned is to get to the point
where you have a team you kind of do
have to go on yet another little side
quest learn how to manage a small team
but once you get to a certain size you
can hire an officer director you can
hire a CEO you can even hire a CEO if
you need to and they can handle the
business aspects for you while you still
stick in the creative Lanes if you want
to that's uh really great advice so on
this topic of how do I make a million
dollars a year from a small channel for
someone listening to this what are some
of the steps or tips that you would try
to apply in a more General sense to
creators so what it really comes down to
is becoming the go-to person in a niche
that has growing demand and that has
good product marketing fit so what we've
done and I'll use what we've done as an
example because I don't want to try to
generalize my advice too much but what
we've done is we realized that I had an
interest in notion I had skill and a lot
of product knowledge there and there was
a large and growing contingent of people
who are very interested in it and there
was uh there was products that we could
build that people actually wanted to buy
so what that created was a very strong
funnel and I think that's what a lot of
creators don't quite understand they
think if I get a lot of views that's
going to somehow lead to money but
that's like pouring water at the edge of
a funnel that's just been cut off right
at the top slice right it's going to go
nowhere it's not going to go into the
bottle you want it to go into so you
have to figure out how do you get people
from the top part of your funnel to the
bottom part of your funnel and if there
are strong transitional points to each
each stage in the funnel that is how you
build a sustainable business so in our
case there's a lot of interest around
notion right now which means that we can
get quite a lot of traffic on videos in
a niche sense it's not Mr Beast level
it's not even uh not even like 100K per
video most times but it's enough people
who are interested enough in this
product and are interested enough in our
products who may pay 129 or 79 if we're
running a sale that kind of thing that
you don't have to have a huge audience
you just have to have enough that come
in and buy at that level so right now we
operate on I believe like a 90 average
order value uh you could do the math in
your head right now it doesn't take a
lot of sales to get to 100 Grand per
month relatively uh when you're at 90
average for Value uh versus with
something like AdSense most people are
getting between what is it like one and
four dollars CPA is the the average that
gets thrown on the industry that's a lot
of people you have to bring in to make
any kind of money at all yeah and it
sounds like you know I think for the
YouTube mindset
um is focused on I have to go viral to
make this sustainable and what's also
interesting was it it all a struggle for
you to have that view differential I
think for some if you don't have a big
visible view count which could be
arguably a vanity metric
it could hurt your ego it could make you
feel like you're not successful as a
YouTuber you're not getting Mr Beast
numbers even the lid or like the height
of your content won't compare to your
other Channel's numbers it's not as much
broad appeal right but it's such a it's
a much more effective business but was
that just easy for you because you saw
behind the scenes or was there any kind
of ego of like well I'm not pulling your
most viewed video as six plus million
views or seven and you're you're not
pulling those numbers but it sets a
niche thing was it an easy transition
for you or is there anything I'll say
there's a slight bit of ego yeah but I
think that I kind of worked through
those ego problems before I even went
full time on Thomas Frank explains yeah
and the reason for that is I had been in
the productivity Niche for so long I was
kind of at the top of it for a while and
then Matt Diablo came along better ideas
came along all the abdall came along and
even before they all passed me up I
could tell like they're going to pass me
up they're either hungrier or they make
better content in certain Dimensions or
they're publishing more often like I can
see the trajectory and I can either
chase that hamster wheel because I want
to satisfy my ego and stay on top or I
can really dig deep and say like what is
it that I actually want to do what
what's the average day that I want to
experience what are the metrics that
actually matter I don't necessarily want
to be a famous person I don't want to be
mobbed when I go to a place like this uh
so chasing the fame is actually
counterintuitive to what I want there's
like that Bill Murray story where he's
like I always tell people who want to be
rich and famous try being rich first see
if that covers all the bases uh and I've
I've definitely realized that as I've
become a little bit less known generally
I'm actually happier I can go more
places not get recognized I can spend
more time on the highly technical Niche
things that actually interest me and
there's an audience there that is so
hungry for that kind of content as well
I can have a sustainable career without
needing to chase the big numbers so at
this point I'm just like I don't really
care yeah as long as I can sustain
myself and especially my team my family
I'm good to go are you ready to start or
grow your YouTube channel do you feel
stuck and need help connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
YouTube success we've helped thousands
of purpose-driven entrepreneurs just
like you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com that's
it's actually you're like a think media
podcast dream guest because we actually
our dream is to help creators reach
Financial Independence and maybe be
unknown in the process because
everyone's chasing Fame and I think Fame
could be overrated yeah some will some
will reach out and maybe that's the
model that most aligns with even the
style of content and perhaps it could be
their desire it could be a toxic desire
but it also could be a good desire if
you want to reach and impact a lot of
people but saying that is so encouraging
that it's possible to make man over a
million dollars a year and Beyond with a
small channel are you focused completely
on YouTube or are you trying to
diversify into vertical video across
platforms right now YouTube uh it's the
thing where I would like to be
diversifying on The Tick Tock onto
YouTube shorts all that kind of stuff
but it comes down to what's my capacity
for creating content right now if I
could someday scale the team to where
they can hand me
um you know a script or something and
it's like here's five shorts you're
gonna film I'm totally down to do that
right now my average day as I come into
the office and I spend the entire day
programming because I've been working on
the same video for two months and uh I
think I think in lumpy analytic terms so
like everyone wants it to have that
smooth hockey stick style curve and they
think you need to have super super
frequent content to do that
um I'm okay with like a little jump and
then Plateau for a while a little jump a
little Plateau for a while because
during those plateaus you have some
breathing room and some time to sort of
go into the cave Tony Stark style and
build something out of a box of scraps
and then you get to go stand on the
stage and present what you've built so
that's the kind of style that really
resonates with me if I could build the
machine around me that would allow me to
also create create content that's in
short form video form without really
digging into that schedule I'm down for
it and you think that now going back to
your other channel how is that going to
be sustainable because you have someone
helping you with scripting two people
helping with scripting got my editor so
by necessity the main channel is going
to have to become I guess my role in the
main channel is going to have to become
more like say a Hank Green on Crash
Course where he's not necessarily the
one writing the chemistry scripts he's
got a script supervisor uh he has
writers he has fact Checkers and he has
a whole editing and post-production team
he can sit down maybe do a table read
for the script get familiar with
material make sure he's into it deliver
it to the camera and make a good show
you become a host almost yeah and and I
think that's actually where the ego
problem lies it's not in the views or
the fame it's like this internal feeling
like I should be part of every step of
the process in every video I make
otherwise it's somehow bad and I've
realized watching other people's shows
that I really enjoy no it's a team
effort you you don't have to so a really
good friend of mine once said like get
clear on what is your ego and what is
your art so like what's the real core of
what you contribute and what you're best
at and what's just the stuff that your
ego says you have to do and cut out that
ego stuff that's really powerful I think
Phil DeFranco has a similar show and
he's also been sustainable he's writers
yes he's delivering the news he can
weave in his personality maybe Veer Off
Script of course and it's always his
personality but he's also created the
machine but that's some very powerful
insights for us to think of maybe a
little bit different about the
trajectory of where our content will go
I want to do a little bit of a lightning
round with you related to maybe books
podcasts influential resources as
someone that is into productivity and
all of the above
um that have helped you in your journey
maybe just personal development in
general what is some of the top books or
audio books that you think creators
should read it could be related to being
a better Creator and maybe also just
having better habits being more
effective and actually getting things
done do you think that the average
person watching this is maybe in the
beginning stages
um we have the average person watching
this could just be starting but we do
have a lot of season craters that are
pretty established and a ton of business
owners that either want to build a
personal brand or use YouTube to get
more leads clients and sales so you
leverage kind of their personal brand
but to grow their business so there's
some diversity here but a lot of think
media is a little bit more advanced as
well gotcha I think a lot of the
consumption I did of books and podcasts
and things were much more at the
beginning stages so I'll give a couple
of recommendations there the main one
for me is a little book like truly
little uh called the motivation hacker
and this was a book that this guy Nick
winter wrote when he was I think like 22
or 23 years old and it was just like
it's a book about how he forced himself
to do a bunch of goals he had and I read
that back in 2013 when I had hit a point
in my blog where I actually got like
that mythical passive income like I was
literally getting like five to seven
Grand a month and I didn't have to do
anything for it in a post that ranks
number one in Google for a high value
keyword and then the rest of my blog was
about nothing like it wasn't about that
at all so people just kept coming in and
I'm like cool I'm living with my college
roommates making Seven Grand a month I
can basically do what I want so for a
year I just played Magic the Gathering
and like tried to get myself to work I
read this book he's like I went to this
exact same problem so what I did is I
signed up for this tool that makes you
bet money that you're gonna do what you
said you were gonna do and if I didn't
write my 500 Words a day I was going to
lose like seven thousand dollars wow and
so I used that tool it was called B
minor I didn't bet seven thousand
dollars I kind of just put more of my
ego in like five bucks on the line but
it transformed my work style it was like
that uh that mindset shift from amateur
to professional professionals show up
they don't wait for inspiration they
come in and they practice the craft
every single day and they dig
inspiration out of the ground so I would
recommend reading that book if people
have troubles with consistency I would
also recommend another very tiny book
called The Dip by Seth Godin uh this was
a very inspiring book for my my
transition from a big YouTuber doing
productivity style content to the niche
content that book is about how to quit
strategically and how to know when to
quit and it's like you can read it an
hour so I don't really need to get a
huge synopsis of it I recommend everyone
read it to identify at what point in my
journey am I am I now trying to exploit
something that is no longer exploitable
am I trying to draw blood from a stone
and what point on my journey do I need
to go explore and do something else of
course we'll link those up in the show
notes as far as a content creator in
terms of Storytelling or structure has
there been any
films or creators or documentaries that
have maybe helped you create content
better be a better artist
I'm very inspired by Edgar Wright films
so Scott Pilgrim hot fuzz those kinds of
ones
um it's hard to say because I really try
to pull my inspiration from a huge
variety of sources give you a great
example I got into this game doing
academic success content there was
nobody on YouTube at the time doing it
well so my original inspiration came
from Crash Course and they were doing
like crash course world history 2 and
biology at the time I want to say uh and
then there were people doing like video
game retrospective videos so people like
categoris and Satchel Drake's and
JonTron back in the day that's where I
pulled a lot of my style inspiration
from in the beginning and I just was
like how can I apply this to my specific
Niche so I would say instead of and I
think this is actually quite important
to say instead of looking at people who
are doing the same kind of content
you're doing and trying to pull a lot of
inspiration from them I think that's how
we get Beast Clones look at somebody
who's in another Niche that you're
interested in and ask yourself like how
can I pull a little bit of what they're
doing and bring it over here because
that's where you get like the whole
steal like an artist ethos right you're
pulling something from a totally
unrelated Niche you bring it to your own
and you're making your own Niche better
without really copying yeah and for that
reference still like an artist another
great book Austin Cleon also show your
work all his books are very cool and uh
there's gonna be a resource Rich episode
in the description are you a podcast
consumer not anymore but you were
previously yeah it was back in the day
any helpful business or entrepreneur
podcast that helped you build your
business
um so there's a new podcast so I used to
I used to co-host a podcast called
listen Money Matters which is a personal
finance show it was my favorite podcast
in college one of the co-hosts left I
basically took his spot so it was your
favorite podcast as a listener yes and
then you eventually were a host on it
yeah so basically the way this worked is
I had my podcast the college info geek
podcast I really wanted to have an
episode about personal finance so I went
on iTunes I found a great personal
finance show emailed the guys we
instantly hit it off we become friends
and then then every single morning I
would listen to their show because they
were daily back then yeah they had a bit
of a falling out one of the coasts left
I was like I don't want this show to die
can I just come take the spot that's
wild and so uh Andrew and I co-hosted
that show for three years I eventually
left and then the original Coast came
back and they also co-hosted a show
called money lab which it is done it's
still online I recommend going through
the archives uh but Andrew recently
started a new show called seeking profit
so if you're interested in online
business that is the current show that I
listen to on occasion when I do listen
to podcasts it's called seeking profit
podcast so we'll link that one up as
well and was that remote for you were
you able to be a co-host on this podcast
just remotely yep and it was Audio Only
yeah it was Audio Only
um and they do there's video now but
they're also remote I mean Riverside FM
is just such a good tool you can build a
whole remote show and you can have
camera angles you know with like a
Riverside and a good black magic setup
you can basically do anything yeah that
yeah we stream yard does something
similarly that's what we use kind of
they call it perfect oh yeah so it's
really crispy on the back end captures
natively on people's computers and then
uploads to the cloud before they jump
off similar and uh yeah video podcast
big opportunity because you could kind
of live anywhere yes and uh still create
great content as long as you got
internet 100 well as we're Landing the
plane
um
is it too late to start YouTube no
why do you say that because the audience
keeps growing and when the audience
grows the micro niches grow too uh so my
favorite example of this is my friend
patch from tier Zoo his channel does
like fighting game style tier rankings
of animals and so like that's a niche
where you're like taking fighting games
in video game culture and then zoology
and mashing that together and he has a
multi-million subscriber Channel now
every single video gets over a million
views that's a niche invented right and
now here I am making uh you know a
million dollars a year it feels like a
brag but like it's about productivity
software yeah you go look at people who
are doing content on obsidian which is
even smaller like they're building
sustainable businesses so YouTube's
audience is always expanding and I think
that as a community we're now learning
more and more and really dialing in on
what it takes to build a great channel
on how to optimize for attention all
this kind of stuff there's more
resources out there than ever the cost
to entry is lower than ever and the
audience is bigger than ever so while
the competition mission is uh both more
numerous and higher skilled your
barriers are lower there's more people
out there
it's worth trying and I think it's
easier than ever to succeed ironically
final two questions because of your
unique perspective as a guest two
different types of listeners to this
podcast the first is trying to break six
figures the second's trying to break
seven figures what advice would you have
for that person that is as a Creator or
entrepreneur so they're maybe creating
content they also are trying to do a
digital product maybe they're going
patreon uh more entertainment brand
deals but they're trying to scale up any
tips for the barrier of six figures I
feel like the answer is kind of the same
for six and seven yeah uh so the the
answer is to optimize for more of you
and what I mean by that is most creators
are looking at how do I increase my
AdSense Revenue through more views or
how do I get sponsorships and brand
deals those are both great ways to
monetize uh I hit six figures quite
easily with sponsorships and brand deals
but when people click on a video of
yours
they're signaling that they want
something they want to watch the video
so the video has a job to be done which
is deliver what it Promises to the
viewer if you slot in a sponsorship or
if you do a mid-roll ad that kind of
harms the video's job right because the
person didn't click on the video to see
an ad for an away suitcase or a
skillshare or whatever it is and those
are great products but that's not what
they came there for if someone clicks on
one of my videos because they want to
build a full stack Creator management
system and notion that's what they want
and if I have a product that I can sell
them like hey I can teach you how to
build this you can do it for free or I
can set it up for you save you tons of
time we have a support that pipeline is
just so obvious so if you can optimize
for more of the thing your audience came
in for and you can productize that that
is the quickest way to six figures and I
think seven figures as well specific to
the question of second seven figures I
know some people who have done this
without scaling but it's easier if you
scale and bring on extra people who can
take off all the things that you are not
the best at so if you can bring in an
Ops person if you can bring an editor I
think editor is the number one hire
everyone should make first thing they
should do is hire an editor if you can
get a VA to handle support or handle um
like customer requests or your email or
whatever it is you have more time to
focus on your content you have more time
to focus on your product offerings and
that is what is going to help you get to
that six and seven seven figure uh
Benchmark I know Alex harmesia had a
great tweet about this he said you don't
get rich by diversifying you get rich by
focusing and then you stay Rich by
diversifying so if you can just batten
down the hatches focus on whatever is
the highest leverage activity you have
access to that's the quickest way to get
there you're a legend super grateful for
all the wisdom you've shared today this
is a very rich strategic and Powerful
podcast so thank you Thomas people of
course can check out everything that
you're doing in the show notes lots of
good resources shared but break it down
if people want to follow you on social
media and then your main both channels
because uh by the time they see this too
we'll be uh blessed to have content on
both channels where can people connect
with you yeah so um the audience here is
creators the main thing that I'll share
is on my website Thomas jfrank.com you
can go to the little blog Tab and
there's a Creator advice section that's
just an area where I've been brain
dumping everything I know about being a
Creator from how to get over
perfectionism to how to optimize your
website speed whenever I think of
something cool I just put it on there
I've got pictures of all the sets I've
ever built behind the scenes stuff like
I'm basically just trying to build that
out into like an online book of
everything I've ever learned so that
might be useful to people who are
watching this Twitter I'm Tom frankly
and then the main channel is thomasfrank
the notion channels Thomas Frank
explains if you want to learn notion and
I think everyone should learn notion I'm
kind of biased no and uh explains I
think I personally have not got into it
but as we wanted to be more productive
that Creator bundle specifically as a
workflow for creators in notion you've
created that is available for purchase
yes you can just plug and play that
right and plug it and play you use it
with your team there's a whole script
area b-roll areas uh topic and thumbnail
and title optimization areas all that
kind of good stuff amazing well
appreciate you Thomas thanks for coming
on the podcast thank you so much for the
opportunity Sean absolutely subscribe if
you're not subscribed share this out
this one's a good one somebody needs to
hear this smash like depending on where
you're listening to it and we will talk
soon think media podcast